No, a helicopter cannot fly 90 degrees
on its side like that. That's crazy.
Hey, fly peeps! I am
Vernice "FlyGirl" Armour,
coming at you.
My name is Andy Stumpf.
I spent just under 17
years as a US Navy SEAL.
My name is Adm. Jamie Foggo.
Peter Rhee.
Mike Elliott.
I'm Nicholas Moran.
Today, I'll be looking
at helicopter scenes.
Warship scenes.
Tank-battle scenes.
Battle-wound scenes.
Parachuting scenes.
Underwater action scenes from movies
and seeing how real they really are.
If you need to cross the
river, cross the river.
You know, there's no
reason to actually pop up
in the middle of it and give
away your tactical advantage.
If you are trying to sneak up on somebody,
you would either cross the
entire thing above the water
or cross the entire thing below the water.
Or go farther down or
upstream and like, you know,
maybe find a log that's across it.
You don't even have to get
wet 'cause being wet sucks.
(dramatic music)
(gunshot)
All right, stop right there.
I have been asked about this
particular scene so many times
because people absolutely love it
and they want to know how we
train to be able to do that.
And here's the answer: we don't.
Because right, you'd never
fall in any other direction.
You just absolutely know
the exact place and time
that somebody's gonna fall
when you shoot them in the head, right?
Because why wouldn't you?
What could possibly go wrong?
But you gotta remember all of
that was preceded by probably
a .762 or a .300 Win Mag round
snapping through the jungle.
The suppressor that's on the rifle,
it's basically a muffler and
it contains some of the gas
and it drastically reduces the
decibel output of the rifle.
But bullets, when they
fly through the air,
they're super sonic.
So it makes a crack and
there is subsonic ammunition
and it's much quieter.
That's not what that person was shooting.
The whole point of doing the
charade of catching somebody
and lowering them into the water
as if it was just eating
them into the abyss,
it's 'cause you're trying to be sneaky.
So going through all this
in attempt to be sneaky
and then cracking off
a round in the jungle,
it defeats the entire purpose.
It just, they're so, it's
not how it works, people.
(dramatic music)
Where you link up with a submarine
in the middle of the ocean,
that's totally plausible.
They were on a zodiac,
which is gonna have probably a
55 or a 35 horsepower engine.
So they could easily go from
a land mass over the horizon
out into international water
or really wherever the sub
would wanna meet and do that,
so that's totally legit.
(dramatic music)
(door clanging shut)
Yeah, wow.
So they obviously had direct support
from the United States
Navy to make this movie
and I'm actually surprised they
showed very much of the SDV,
which stands for Seal Delivery Vehicle.
In essence, it is a miniature submarine.
It's smaller, harder to be discovered,
and you can move people and
equipment a really far distance
and then go back to the submarine too
'cause you can go back and
relink back up to that asset
that you departed from.
You are in your dive gear
until that dive is over
and it can be up to 14 hours.
A lot of the times you're in dry suits.
Dry and warm are two very different things
the people should not confuse.
They nailed it.
It's very plausible that
all of that would occur
on an SDV operation.
I'm gonna give 'em a 10 on that.
The sniper water river catch is a zero.
It actually might be a negative number.
(dramatic music)
Is there a more obvious way
to let somebody know that you're coming
than white and orange
parachutes in the daytime
jumping directly over the top of them.
Surprise!
You didn't see that coming.
I've worn dive fins on my
feet for a free fall jump
and actually was falling
through the air with them on.
More often than not though,
the back strap of the fin,
you put your feet through that
and you actually taped
the fin up to your leg.
But if you're gonna land in the water,
you're gonna want to have fins on you.
In case you need to
have the ability to swim
or exert yourself, you're
gonna need those fins.
(dramatic music)
(spear guns firing)
(laughing)
Yes.
And they had a fleet,
a full fleet of submersibles
with spear guns.
I am not aware of any engagement
at any time in the history
of human beings where anything
like this has occurred.
We are not trying to get
into fights in the water,
like bottom line.
We use it as a way to
disguise what we're doing
or to get from A to B,
or to be sneaky, right?
To like, well I don't
know where they went.
Like bloop, here we
are, we're in the water.
You didn't see us, surprise!
We're not looking to
get into a fight ever.
So no, we're not bringing
tridents or spears
or any of that stuff.
(dramatic music)
I like how they're cutting the hoses.
Unfortunately, there is
usually an inhalation hose
and an exhalation hose and they
probably could still breathe
if they caught the wrong one.
We always had dive knives on us,
but it's for like cutting gear
if something gets hung up.
There was never a thought in my mind ever
of pulling that out with the
intent of fighting with it.
It was for anything but that.
Like Phillip's head screws,
using the tip of your,
like that's the only use dive knives for.
(dramatic music)
I like the idea of what
he's got in his mouth.
I'll call that the Gen One Spare Air,
which with a canister of that size
I feel like you have about
a one half of one breath.
So he certainly wouldn't
be able to stay underwater.
(dramatic music)
And then the concussive
device in the water.
Concussion and the way that
shock waves travel underwater
is a very, very real thing.
Let's just say that was
a grenade of some kind.
That would probably kill the people
inside of that contained area,
but it probably would
damage him a little bit too,
especially if there's
open windows and portholes
'cause that stuff will bounce out as well.
So it's plausible, but I would say
you would wanna get outta
the (beep) outta there
before that thing went off,
like out of the water
before that thing went off.
I don't even know if I can give
this one a technical review.
- I found door number
three and I'm taking it.
(dramatic music)
- Oh that's a national treasure, alright.
You know jumping off of,
I think it was the aircraft carrier,
that's probably gonna be 50, 60 feet.
I'm here for that.
That's definitely survivable.
You could definitely do that.
(dramatic music)
So we navigated with, we
called them nav boards
and we had three really
exciting items on there
that we used to get to stare
at for hours at a time.
The first one you already
mentioned was a compass.
The next entertaining
tool was a depth gauge,
and lastly a stopwatch.
That was it.
We dive in pairs,
but only one person gets
the navigation board.
So somebody else out there is
just like, "I hate my life.
This dive is taking forever.
I don't even have anything to look at."
So sometimes when I was the buddy
I would just swim on top of my dive buddy
and just look at the navigation board too,
because I was so bored.
I just wanted to look at numbers
slowly just like creeping around.
(dramatic music)
- [Sadusky] Can you
see Gates in the water?
- Sir, it's the Hudson,
nothing is visible.
- So all these people that
are above them looking down
are gonna see the bubbles.
This would be an example
of where a closed circuit
would be better than open circuit.
Because even though that guy
grabbed him right under water,
every time they exhale,
the bubbles are coming up.
It's actually really easy
to track divers' progress
from above when they're
breathing open circuit.
Open circuit, you can see the bubbles.
Closed circuit, you can be sneaky.
It's just a closed loop system
that only allows the gas to
flow through in one direction
'cause obviously you wouldn't
want it coming back and forth,
and you push it through
a chemical scrubber,
it pulls out the carbon dioxide
and boom, you're off and running.
There's 100% chance that
you could actually do that.
But if you wanted to do it
and actually not be seen,
I'd say closed circuit is a better option.
I'll give 'em a seven.
- Hi, my name is Peter Rhee.
I served in the military for 24 years
and I'm a trauma surgeon.
I was one of the first
surgeons into Afghanistan.
Today, we're going to be
looking at battle wound scenes.
(people yelling)
- Jesus.
- Bringing it in, bringing it in.
- I said get his guts in now.
(gunfire)
- What they're trying to
show is an evisceration.
So a guy got hit, they're
taking enemy fire,
high velocity weapons,
AK-47s out there getting hit
and then you eviscerate your organs.
They're making an attempt
to push it back in,
you can't do it.
It doesn't work that way.
The ones I saw were from
exit wounds of AK-47s
through a little small plum size hole.
You will shove everything
out because you got pressure
as you're grunting and
moaning from the pain
and then you can't shove it back in
because it just pops right back out.
So unless they're chemically
paralyzed by intubating them,
it's a waste of time.
In penetrating injury when we're
talking about bullet wounds
and so on like that,
the main thing is just get
them to me as soon as you can
and stop the bleeding.
If it's not your heart
and your major vessels,
we can save you.
If you don't hit those,
the rest we can repair.
- Hey, hey, look at me!
- Now the one thing I
hate when they do movies
is every time you get
some sort of torso injury,
they make them spit blood
and that doesn't happen.
Unless you get shot in the mouth
or you have something
going through your cheeks
and your throat up high.
You don't vomit blood
from getting a gut shot
or anything like that.
- Mayday, up!
(man groaning)
(helicopter blades whirring)
- Let's move!
- The one thing I do like
is they do show how difficult it is
to move a heavy body out there.
These are two to 300 pound
masses that you gotta drag
and two guys pulling these
things is not that easy to do.
I think that part's well done.
(helicopter blades whirring)
You'd never drop in a bird
when there's fire going on.
A bird's not gonna come down
to go do a casualty evacuation
when they're gonna be shooting
at a $40 million bird up in the air.
It'll only land when it's a
really secure landing zone.
I'd give it about a six.
- Expected fleet.
Priority.
He's gone.
- It's a great movie.
It's pretty well done.
The triage in the field is very different
than triage when you come
to a medical company.
You're not doing so much of this
actually during the heat
of the battle itself,
it's usually once the the
initial firefight gets done.
There's four categories when we triage.
So, he went through all
four of 'em dead, expectant,
they need your help,
and then they're okay.
The guy's hollering and yelling.
If they're yelling, they're
okay, so it's a routine.
And then he had one guy that's a priority,
and then that guy was already dead.
Confirming someone that's
dead in few seconds
is not easy to do.
I was in Ramadi when we had
200 people that were bombed
at one time from one bomb.
We got 70 of these casualties
that came right to us
just coming in and they
all come in one by one
and I was the triage officer.
The first marine I got was expecting,
but I couldn't tell for sure
because I only had literally
four or five seconds
to decide whether he was dead or not,
and there was no way we
could use our resources
to work on them.
So what you're doing is trying
to cherry pick the easy saves
so you don't want to to
spend too much time on it,
which is very different than
what we do in civilian trauma.
In civilian trauma we go full
bore, hardcore, team of 12
on top of one person for hours and hours.
And that's not something
you can do in the military.
I give it at nine.
- Stay with me, stay with me.
- Talk to me, guys, talk
to me, what happened?
- Is that Kirk?
(beep) man.
- There's some realism in there.
This is an outpost.
This looks like Army.
So army Italian base station.
Army will usually have a medic
or they'll have a physician's assistant.
Usually with as much webbing and stuff,
the unit that they're in, the housing unit
is paper thin.
So the bullets will go
right through there.
They should be a little bit more fortified
with the Hesco barriers or dirt.
You notice that the guy is bagging a guy
'cause he's not breathing well
and they're about to do CPR.
We don't do that out there.
If they need CPR, that's wasting time
because they need blood.
- Medevac won't be here for a few hours,
which means he needs fresh
blood if he wants to live.
This is the only thing we can do.
We're not sterile and we
can't test for disease.
Our fresh blood is all
we can do to save him.
- Gloves again with the bloody hands,
that's not really realistic.
They have gloves at this point.
When I went out there,
we started doing this for the first time,
we actually started to really
use warm, fresh whole blood,
which is miraculous.
It's unbelievably miraculous.
We can't do that in the civilian world.
But we did walking blood bank.
In my unit in Ramadi, Charlie
Med, two surgeon shop,
we had about 60-70 medics with us as well.
The base was about 600 people.
So we'd go to the chow hall
and there would be a guy that screams out
"Walking blood bank."
Everybody would spit out their food,
go line up at my medical
company, check their dog tags,
they'd lay down on a
floor, they would poke 'em,
get a bag of blood.
We would do a little test
to see if they were
compatible, and we used it.
So from that perspective, it's true.
There's a lot of little mistakes
that they made through here
in order to dramatize it
and they can get away
with it for most people,
but you know, you wouldn't
be walking up to 'em
and giving them your blood
standing up and things like that.
At least they're wearing
the right uniform,
so I give 'em seven.
(explosion)
(man screaming)
This is a really good scene.
When that explosion
went off in slow motion,
you could see the boot
flying right at the camera.
It's a little bit unusual
from an injury point of view.
A shell coming in hitting the ground
would take his legs off like that
because seeing bilateral
amputees at the thigh
has been a really recent
injury that we never saw before
in previous wars.
We didn't really see bilateral
amputations above the knee.
Before, in the other war movies,
they would step on claymores and landmines
and those were actually meant to take off
your foot and your ankle.
So the medics would come out
and then you'd sniper the
medics and get more casualties.
So it wasn't really supposed
to be a mortal wound.
His was mangled below the knee,
but obviously his was going to be close
to what we were seeing in Iraq
where they would just
build these huge bombs
and bury them into the ground.
We were seeing just legs blown sky high.
(man grunting)
I could do three hours on tourniquets.
Blood loss is the number
one preventable loss
that we want to avoid.
Some of the soldiers,
they even wear tourniquets
when they're going out there.
Actually what we are
recommending and what we teach
is that they put on your own tourniquets.
The tourniquets are problematic
because if you don't put it on right
and if it's not on absolutely
the tightest it can be,
you'll bleed more and you'll bleed out.
When you put it on,
you gotta commit to it.
You gotta go full bore.
And I tell you, putting a tourniquet on
will be the most painful
thing you experience
about three to four minutes.
It's like your leg is falling off.
So, it is something you
do as a last resort.
It will save lives, but
you gotta go for it,
otherwise you will actually bleed more.
(man groaning)
- Here comes the morphine,
here comes the morphine.
It's gonna kick in real quick, Ralph.
We're gonna get you shifted.
- In the old days, morphine was good.
We got scared of it
because morphine can definitely kill you.
If you take a person
who's low blood pressure,
not a blood circulating
and then you give it,
then it can depress your cardiac function
and then you can die, you
would also stop breathing.
So we've actually gone away
from morphine in the field.
We use a new drug called ketamine.
While it provides a lot of relief of pain,
it does not lower your blood pressure.
So, that's the reason why we use it.
The medics can do a lot and
they're so vitally important,
but a lot of the movies is,
I think the audience doesn't
understand that a medic
is not a trauma surgeon.
Trauma surgeon obviously
went to medical school,
did five years of general surgery,
then two years of training
as a trauma surgeon.
So seven years of training
like a brain surgeon.
The medic's job is to get 'em to us,
not to clamp things in the field.
It's pretty good.
I'd say give it a nine.
- My name is Admiral Jamie Foggo
and I served in the Navy
for almost 40 years.
When I retired I took over
as Dean of the Center
for Maritime Strategy
of the Navy League here in Washington, DC.
Today, we're gonna be looking
at warship scenes from movies.
(dramatic music)
- Second torpedo to starboard beam!
Bearing 1-2-0.
(dramatic music)
- "Greyhound" is an
absolutely phenomenal movie.
It tells and depicts with
great historical accuracy.
The Germans are depicted in the movie
as deploying the wolf pack
tactics, and you know,
you see two torpedoes coming
from different directions,
you know that's more than
one submarine firing.
And these tactics were
extremely effective.
(dramatic music)
- Meter, meter!
- So what you see on
the bridge of the ship
is an attack on the destroyer.
I think that was very realistic.
And you see the wake of the
torpedo coming towards you.
The propellers do something
that we call cavitate.
They create bubbles as they're
going through the water
and that creates a trail
behind the torpedo.
And so, a sharp lookout
can pick that up early
and it gives the commanding
officer an advantage
to conduct those drastic
evasive maneuvers.
If it was nighttime, a lot of times
it's even easier to see the torpedo
because of the
phosphorescence in the water.
It kind of glows as it's coming at you.
A lot of these torpedoes
were electric powered.
They had batteries and
electric motors in them
and they would go towards the target.
Nowadays we have torpedoes
that are propelled by fuel
and have a very long range.
And so it was a different game back then,
but in this case, absolutely accurate.
(dramatic music)
As far as the maneuverability is concerned
of that destroyer,
you have to keep in mind
this is not a battleship
that displaces 50,000 tons.
These are lighter ships nowadays,
heavy destroyer in the United States Navy
is about 7,800-8,000 tons.
The propulsion systems
on these destroyers,
the engines and the
propellers and the rudders
are made for speed and maneuverability.
Particularly because in the
Second Battle of the Atlantic,
they were not only going
after surface ships,
they were going after submarines.
And that means you've gotta
be able to turn on a dime.
(dramatic music)
(ships guns firing)
The rounds that actually hit the water
or penetrate the water,
whether or not they actually
do any damage, it depends.
As soon as you know a .50
caliber round hits water,
typically it ricochets.
If it does go beneath the water line,
you lose velocity very quickly.
So, it's highly unlikely
that that would penetrate
any kind of steel hull.
But again, you never know.
(dramatic music)
(ships guns firing)
So he has to surface
because water's coming in.
And then, while he's on the surface,
they finish him off in pretty
much of a brutal manner.
But you see what looks
like anti-aircraft guns
that are lowered to the deck plate level.
As this projectile went in and it blew up,
it may have caused secondary explosions.
First there's an initial
boom and then a massive boom.
There's so much oil and fuel and weapons
on board that submarine that, you know,
once it took that initial
penetration of the hull
and those shape charges
went in and exploded.
This movie gets absolutely
top marks for me.
As far as realism, 10 outta 10.
- Cradle lowered.
- Right, I'll ram the projectile.
- Easy!
- When you ram that
powder, you ram it easy.
- Real easy.
- This is one of the most accurate movies
on how you load a 16-inch
projectile into a 16-inch barrel.
That projectile weighs 2,000 pounds.
So you're essentially
loading a a Volkswagen beetle
into the breach of that gun
and firing it at the enemy.
And you notice that the projectile,
it's followed by these powder charges.
This was a very accurate representation
of how you load that gun.
There are spark proof tools
and everybody is very careful
because you know that powder
is obviously explosive and volatile
and any mistake or any spark
or any flame could set it off
and blow up that turret.
- 2-0-4 degrees, Calloway.
(beeping)
2-0-4 degrees.
- 2-0-4 degrees.
- This very shiny brass
device, that's a gun site,
and that's to allow the gun
captain to take a look out
and see the direction that he's firing in.
That's the way that we used to do it.
Before we had these very
sophisticated fire control radars
and gun directors that are
on top of the turrets today.
- My fire in the hole.
(explosion)
(man yelling)
- I got a chuckle out of the fact
that Tommy Lee Jones runs
toward the 16-inch gun turret
just before it's fired.
We had, on the battleships, procedures
to prevent sailors from being topside
in proximity to those turrets
when they fire the guns,
because the over pressure of the blast
blew 'em back, you know,
a dozen or so feet.
And that's probably fairly accurate.
Even today, with our missile systems,
if you're launching from the
fore deck of a destroyer,
nobody's up there when you're launching
because there's gonna be
a lot of flash to bang
as the weapon comes out the tube
and you don't want anybody to get hurt.
I'd give it a seven outta 10.
(dramatic music)
"Battleship" happens to be
one of my favorite movies.
These are World War II era ships.
They're not part of the
active fleet anymore,
but these ships are made to fight
and when you're on one
of those battleships
and you have a belt of armor around you,
12 to 17 inches thick
and 50,000 tons of steel
to protect you, that's pretty reassuring.
- Drop port anchor.
- What?
(anchor clanging)
(water splashing)
- The officer of the deck on the bridge
uses the anchor on the
battleship to avoid getting hit
by some of the aliens weapons.
Frankly, that's pretty hokey.
The amount of chain on a
battleship or an aircraft carrier
connected to the anchor is pretty long.
You know, it's probably
at least 1,000 feet
but we don't use anchors for that reason.
We use anchors to more the ship in port
and this is in the Pacific
Ocean, which is really deep.
(guns firing)
(dramatic music)
One thing that the
viewers might not notice
is it's so powerful
that the ship actually moves
sideways several yards.
When you fire a broad side,
oh it can move significantly
and you have to do a
course correction there.
I'd probably give it a two.
I think Hollywood took
a little poetic license
on the anchor in this case.
- Hey, fly peeps, I am
Vernice Fly Girl Armor
coming at you.
And back in 2003,
I became America's first
Black female combat pilot
serving two tours in Iraq.
Today, I'll be looking at
helicopter scenes in movies.
(dramatic music)
(helicopter blades whirring)
Flying in formation in
helicopters is very common.
We practice it a lot.
We will land together,
we'll take off together.
And in an environment like this
where you have that mission
where you're dropping off
say a flight of soldiers in this case,
yeah that would absolutely
happen like that.
(helicopter blades whirring)
(dramatic music)
(explosion)
Just everything about
that combat maneuver,
the insertion, them dropping.
That's why we don't do static
things like that anymore
in combat because of the vulnerability
and the helicopter has pretty
much no maneuverability
when you're in that close
to be able to get out really quick,
a helicopter just doesn't move quick.
A helicopter has to build up
momentum and get going, right?
RPGs are a huge threat to helicopters,
especially if we're flying
what we call low and slow.
But I remember flying in
combat and we just saw the,
and it was early on in combat
and I just saw these great clouds of mist
and we were trying to figure out
like what are those clouds of mist?
And they were RPGs that had
been programmed to explode
at 200 and 300 feet.
And some of my buddies
were impacted by RPGs.
Huge threat.
(helicopter blades whirring)
(people yelling)
(crashing)
So the one I would say
unrealistic part of that clip.
When that RPG hit the tail
rotor of that aircraft,
I thought it would've
been spinning a lot faster
and it wasn't gliding down without power.
And at the very end,
if he tried to cushion
the landing a little bit,
which we're taught to do
in that kind of situation
with the loss of tail rotor,
we would've tried to circle around
in the direction that it's spinning
to have a little control.
But it wouldn't have just landed flat
like you saw in that video.
So the guys in the back,
hopefully they're tied in
or they would just
immediately be thrown out
just like a car accident that twirls over
and everybody gets ejected
out of the vehicle.
The reason I think they
show or film more Helos
getting hit in the tail rotor
just 'cause it's more dramatic.
You get hit in the tail rotor,
you're immediately gonna start spinning
and go outta control.
If you get hit in the main rotor,
you just explode and fall out the sky.
Which one's more exciting?
On a scale of one to 10, nine.
(dramatic music)
(guns firing)
Guns at the front of
the attack helicopters.
Is that realistic?
Absolutely.
I had a 20 millimeter
gatlin gun, three barrel,
it rolled around and
delivered lots of bullets
very fast on target.
So yes, 100% realistic.
Only the pilots would fire that weapon.
(dramatic music)
You see two rocket launchers left,
right then two missile
launchers left and right.
There are 26 rockets in
each one of those pods.
Then there are four
missiles on the end board.
That is actually a standard payload
for an attack helicopter.
(rockets firing)
(explosions)
The rockets are called 2.75-inch rockets.
So they're about this big
around, right, 2.75 inches
and they're pretty long.
The rockets are just like bullets.
You aim, you shoot, you pull,
they go wherever wind shear impacts them.
The hellfire missiles
are laser guided, right?
So they're guided by a laser
to a particular target.
A rocket, it impacts a small area.
Let's say it's 20 feet, 30 feet.
These rockets are
basically just, you know,
as soon as they hit, they
explode and it's a point target.
The missile has a lot more
explosive power to it.
You could shoot a tank or a
building, it's gonna explode.
There are heat seeking missiles
and missiles that can fly to
catch a jet per se, right?
But those aren't the kind of
missiles that, number one,
were on this aircraft.
And number two, helicopters
don't normally carry them.
And they don't follow humans.
And I doubt his jet pack had enough heat
coming off 'cause it probably
would've burned up his legs
if that were the case.
(dramatic music)
There would've been no way
they could just glide into
going through the vortices
of the helicopter.
I could easily see them being
blown down 50 to 100 feet
just like that.
The payload, that was actually realistic.
The heat seeking missiles, not so much.
I'm gonna give it a seven.
(explosion)
(helicopter blades whirring)
(dramatic music)
You can't fly through something like that.
Unrealistic.
Rotors would've already
fallen off the aircraft.
As hard as rotor blades look,
they're very sensitive and
finely tuned and balanced.
And as soon as it impacts an object,
you're not gonna be able to
fly the aircraft after that.
- Hurry up!
- Because it's The Rock,
could have been realistic
with him hanging on the side.
It's like hanging onto a car, right?
Because most of the
downward push of the wind
from a helicopter is on the
last third of the blades.
It's not in the in the very center.
So, the wind shear
wouldn't have pushed him
out of the middle.
Totally unrealistic.
It's just like the wheel of a car.
It's never in one position.
It's constantly moving.
Where'd he get the piece
of metal to even fix it?
When they showed it in that
clip, it was just stable.
He was actually able
to hold it and the rod.
It's just not gonna be stable like that.
(person yelling)
No, a helicopter can not fly 90 degrees
on its side like that.
That was crazy.
I would give it a one.
- Greetings all.
I'm Nicholas Moran.
I'm commissioned as an Armor Officer
on M1 tanks and then M3 Bradleys.
These days, my work as
a civilian historian
for the publisher of World of Tanks.
Today we're gonna be looking
at tank battle scenes.
(explosion)
And that is absolutely accurate.
The vast majority of
tanks that were destroyed
had no idea that the enemy was there.
And again, this is why
you always have to work
in conjunction with infantry
because they have more eyes than you do.
They have better vision than you do.
But more often than not,
the first indication
that somebody is there
is when you get shot at.
And knocking off either
the first or the last tank
in an ambush in a row
like that is classic.
(people yelling)
(dramatic music)
- 88, it's a goddamn tank.
- With regard to the TCs in this case,
keeping their heads out, there
are two schools of thought,
but certainly in the time
period of World War II
all the way through the
Cold War, even myself,
it would be in a head out position.
The Western school of thought
is you keep your head out,
because what you don't see will kill you.
The other school of thought,
such as used by the Soviet
Army in the Cold War
was that you wanted to operate head down.
So you close the hatch.
No artillery could affect you,
no snipers could affect you.
And the problem of course is the reverse.
You aren't able to see
whatever is about to kill you.
So there is a balance to be struck.
- Right, all tanks move forward.
(tanks accelerating)
- War daddy has decided for some reason
that he's going to charge the enemy tank,
I'm not sure I would've
done quite the same thing
because that simplifies
the problem for the enemy
and just give them
three targets in a line.
If you can have what's
called a base of fire
and then a maneuver element,
then the enemy tank has a choice.
He can engage the guy
that's just sitting there
pumping accurate shots at you,
or the German tank can
engage the flanking element
who are coming around the side
and the 76-millimeter
gun on two of these tanks
actually would destroy a Tiger.
(muffled yelling)
Okay, so being obscured,
the German tank has decided
to advance out of the smoke
as opposed to just sit there
and wait for whatever the
enemy were going to do.
The Germans were very, very
big on individual initiative.
The concept is called Auftragstaktik.
These days we use a development of it
called Mission Command.
But the bottom line is
you don't wait for orders,
you take the initiative, you
make a decision on the spot.
And that is exactly what
the German has done here.
- Fivel, put it up his (beep)
where the armor's thin.
- I know to (beep) hit him.
- The radical is accurate for
a World War II American tank.
And Shia, in this case is
using the coaxial telescope.
So you're gonna see
graduations on the radical.
Each graduation is for a type
of round at a certain range.
So if your target is let's say 800 yards,
you will elevate the gun so
that the 800 yard graduation
is on the target.
So the single biggest cause
of missing in World War II
was range estimation error.
If you get the range wrong,
it doesn't matter if your aim is correct,
you will go over or short.
Which is why we now have
modern fire control systems
to do all that mathematics for you.
(bullets clanging)
- Again!
(dramatic music)
- If you're in this sort of a knife fight,
which I wouldn't recommend getting into.
The first round set the engine alight,
but that doesn't necessarily
say that the tank crew
and turret can't still get a shot off.
You say you shoot at a tank until it burns
or changes shape.
So keep shooting until you
know that the threat is gone.
This scene is an easy nine.
What "Fury" lacks in perhaps
some of the technical accuracy,
it more than makes up for an understanding
the experience of being a tank crewman.
(dramatic music)
(gun squeaking)
This is absolutely correct.
There's gun crews on
each side of the Sponson.
The tank is based off of
a Mark VII International,
which was a very late World War I tank
built by both the UK and US.
And at the time, British tanks,
the heavy tanks had what
were called Sponson guns.
The turret, that wasn't on the Mark VIII.
(yelling)
Shouting instructions to
each other wouldn't happen.
It's too loud.
Inside a World War I tank,
the entire middle of that tank
was taken up by the engine.
It was massive noise.
What he's doing there,
he's using hand signals.
That's the only way to communicate
inside a World War I tank.
(dramatic music)
(explosion)
Firing a gun with anything
in the barrel is bad.
You're under risk of
exactly what happened here.
It's called petaling.
When the gun barrel just
petals out like a flower
and your gun is done.
Oftentimes you'll see a tank
will have a rubber muzzle cap
on the end purely to stop any dirt at all
from getting into it.
And it's designed that you can actually
shoot through the muzzle cap.
(dramatic music)
To my knowledge, on tank fighting
has never been trained in any army.
Personally, I'd have just
stuck my head out the top,
used a pistol, but again,
not very dramatic and it
will kind of suck for Indie.
I would have to give the scene
maybe a three on feasibility grounds.
(dramatic music)
(people yelling)
A Tiger has appeared on the scene.
A Tiger had a mythical
status in World War II.
It had a reputation because
it was very, very hard to kill
and because it had a heck of a gun,
the 8.8 centimeter was lethal
to basically everything.
The problem was that it looks
very much like a Panzer IV,
which is a lot more common.
In actuality, historians
have found very few times
on the western front
that American soldiers
ever actually met a Tiger.
But for the purposes of
drama, a Tiger is fine.
(dramatic music)
This was pretty realistic.
Drivers are absolutely
blind inside their tanks
and they're utterly
reliant on instructions
from the commander.
So that's how you would
get up close to a tank
low below the line of vision,
below the the level of depression
that the guns can aim at you.
(tank squeaking)
They're going for the wheels.
Because the Tiger was a breakthrough tank,
it was heavily armored everywhere.
And if you're infantry,
and you don't have high-velocity cannons,
your best bet is to disable the tank
and get what's called a mobility kill.
To immobilize the tank.
Your two choices are gonna be
either the engine compartment
or the running gear.
And the only thing that these sticky bombs
are going to have any particular effect on
will be the running gear.
So the sticky bomb, it was in the manual,
but it is also almost a
weapon of desperation.
The military is supposed to
give you tools for the job.
Late World War II era, you're
talking about the bazooka.
Now the problem is that you
only have so many rounds
of bazooka ammunition and a
bazooka is only so effective
against something as
heavily armored as a Tiger.
So you're in desperation
mode to start with.
- Both sides!
Get aboard!
Get a grenade!
- So now we see one of the problems
with a tank going on its own.
A tank shouldn't go on its
own for several reasons,
but when you have infantry,
an infestation we might
like to say as tankers,
crawling on your tank, there's a process
that's called scratching
your friend's back.
What you do is you get on the radio,
you call your buddy with a machine gun
and he will machine gun your tank.
Of course the bullets aren't
gonna affect your tank,
you're in a tank,
but it will very much
clean off, or delouse,
the infantry that are
crawling on your tank.
(guns firing)
And that's your example of delousing.
So, the 20-millimeter anti-aircraft gun,
like any anti-aircraft gun
with a high rate of fire,
you aim that thing horizontally
and you will do a number on infantry.
If there's any big myth about tanks,
it's probably that they're
these invulnerable fortresses.
In reality, they're
not invulnerable at all
and they're absolutely
reliant on the other parts
of the Combined Arms team.
You have the desperation
of lightly armed infantry.
You have this back scratching.
You have the immobilization
of a very dangerous tank.
I mean this is easily on the nine scale.
- Hi, I'm Mike Elliott,
a 26-year combat veteran.
I served 11 years
with the US Army Golden
Knight Parachute team.
I have over 16,000
skydives, 6,000 tandems,
100 static line jumps and about
20 military free fall jumps.
Today we're gonna be looking
at parachuting scenes in movies.
(dramatic music)
- Come on, come on, come on.
- So I think you did
the correct procedures.
With military free fall
jumpers with combat equipment,
they have their O2 masks on, goggles.
It's a lot of moving parts.
So there is a possibility that
something could come loose.
It takes about 15 seconds
to to fix his O2 pipe
and put it back to its helmet.
You can hold your breath up
to a minute and still be okay.
So he had plenty of time to fix his mask
and still leave the aircraft.
(dramatic music)
His body position is very correct here.
He's in what we call a dive position.
And it is so uber important
to have the correct body position.
Basically you have to learn
how to push air with your body.
So the wind is basically
hitting him around his waist
and chest area,
which allows that wind to be
symmetrical around his body
so he can gain stability
after he exits the aircraft.
- 25,000 feet.
- You did a very great
job as a HALO jumper.
Basically, HALO is high
altitude, low opening,
meaning you exit the
aircraft above 15,000 feet.
You have to have some type
of breathing apparatus
in the aircraft as well as on your body.
As far as the form is concerned,
there's no different form with HALO.
It's called the the box man
position or the arch position.
Everything he's doing in
this scene is done correctly.
Your knees are bent, your
pelvis is pushed forward,
your arms are back.
(dramatic music)
That is a pretty gnarly looking storm.
I have never had to jump
into clouds and lightning,
and it's not even approved
by the Federal Aviation Administration.
With clouds, you cannot see the ground
and you can get struck by lightning.
And if you flying with other jumpers,
now you at a risk of
running into another person.
And when you slam into another
person at 120 miles per hour,
it's gonna be some serious injuries.
(heavy breathing)
- 4,000.
Deploy, deploy, deploy!
- I do like that the body
position of both actors
in this movie are correct.
And if you're unconscious
and you're going to be on your back
because your arms and legs
are the lowest portions of your body.
So gravity will put you on your back.
I would rate this a high seven for sure.
All those are very unique maneuvers
that could possibly happen.
(air rushing)
A total high five on this scene
from the ramp to the exit.
With a military free fall operation,
each group that's exiting
aircraft has a team leader
and you're guiding all the guys.
So they're grouping around him
so they can see what's going on.
And that's the same formation they stay in
during their exit and as
they get out into free fall.
As you see here, they
jumping at nighttime.
Everything gets really,
really difficult at nighttime
because you're either flying through NODs
or just with your naked eye
and you can't see obstacles,
you can't see the ground coming up.
And in the army you have
the round static line jumps
from like the 82nd Air 1 Division
and you have the army parachute team,
which are demonstrations
and competitive type guys.
On the Special Operation side,
US Navy Seals or Delta
Forces or Special Forces,
these guys are trained
to put that parachute
where they need to put it to
do what they need to do best.
So if these guys are
illustrating from a spec op side,
yes, that is something that
can definitely be done.
(dramatic music)
In this particular scene,
they're doing a HALO,
special operation soldiers,
their thing is to be as
stealthy and as quiet
and as dark as they can.
And the premise of a HALO jump
is soldiers could step out
up to 40 or 50 miles away
at 25,000 feet,
open their parachute by 20,000 feet
and they can drift in quietly, stealthily,
undetected from miles away.
For this, I don't know
why they would have smoke,
especially, all you can't
see smoke at nighttime.
It is mandatory to have
blinking lights on your body,
when you're flying at nighttime,
so other aircraft could see you.
Special Operation guys,
they're not gonna have
any lights and flares
because they're coming in as stealthily,
as quiet as possible
so they can do the mission
once they get on the ground.
The landing, as you see,
it's a extremely tight area.
The tight parachutes that
military special op guys,
are called MC-4/MC-5s.
Very big, very docile parachutes.
They definitely can land on
buildings and tight areas.
I don't think they would
land in something that tight.
Not a bad looking clip at all.
I would give them a six.
(people yelling)
(dramatic music)
Being able to grip and hold
on is virtually impossible.
That parachute is designed for one person
and you're not hooked up properly
as if you're doing a tandem.
But if I knew there was a possibility
that parachute could save both our lives,
then I would make that attempt to do that.
(dramatic music)
I was trying to look and see
what their alterminal reading was.
I couldn't really see, I see
it's flashing low altitude,
but we have no idea of how low they are
before they open up their main parachute.
2,500 feet is when you open
up your main parachute.
Takes time for those things to fully open.
With today's parachute systems,
we have what we call a
automatic opening device.
It's gonna open up the
reserve parachute for you
and that is designed to
open at a low altitude.
So your main parachute,
which they're using in this scene,
they could open up at
that lower of an altitude
is not very realistic.
(dramatic music)
(person screaming)
To have someone attached
to you and land on a target
that's not doing a tandem,
absolutely impossible.
It's called parachute accuracy.
Two people under one parachute,
somebody's gonna break
some ankles for sure.
In that case, they should
have did what we call
a parachute landing fall,
where you hit the balls of
your feet, calve, thighs,
and your buttocks, which is
the softest part of your body.
So trying to land and roll
to those soft sides of your body
is kind of what they did in this scene,
but there's just no way
that you can even see
around that person enough
to fly that parachute
to a target area.
I'm gonna rate these guys at a five.
Wow, I mean, every time I
see a static line operation
at this depth, it gives me chill bumps
to think about soldiers in World War II,
the forefathers of parachuting.
With static line jumping,
it's the most expedient way
to put soldiers on a battlefield.
If you look at some of the actual footage
that happened on D-Day and Market Garden,
that's basically what you see.
Numerous, numerous parachutes
in the air in any given time.
(lines creaking)
So, this is absolutely 100% correct.
I was actually an airborne
instructor for three years
where I trained parachuters
how to become paratroopers.
And the best way to get out
the aircraft is basically
you pushing the guy in
front of you out the door
so you can get out the
door as quick as possible,
and as you exit, you get into
a good tight body position,
which is your hands over your harness,
feet and knees together.
And that static line actually
pulls your parachute out
and your parachute opens automatically.
I'm gonna rate this as a 10.
Just amazing any and every time I see
what the guy's done for
us back in World War II.